écoutez nous allons tirer les meilleures
conclusions de toutes les auditions
voyez nous devons être à 22 ou 23
audition à cette heure-ci et beaucoup
sont prévues vous avez raison de dire
qu'il y a encore du flou parce que je
vois bien et tout le monde tous les
téléspectateurs qui regardent public
sénat peuvent voir qu'il y à des efforts
considérables pour nous expliquer que
monsieur benalla ne s'occuper que des
déplacements
à un moment je me suis demandé si
c'était devenu un agent de voyage ou
s'il était un gentil organisateur comme
on dit au club med
voyez c'est à dire qu' il ya des efforts
pour nous dire mais non il n'exerçait
pas de missions de police ou de sécurité
or nous avons toujours le permis de port
d'armes dans lequel il est écrit
considérant que monsieur benalla exerce
des missions de police de police et puis
nous voyons qu'il est très impliquée
dans toute une série d'opérations
nous le voyons bien alors il y à une
sorte de discours officiels comme a dit
philippe bas qui devient quand même
difficilement crédible et qu'il est même
discours depuis le mois de juillet de la
part des représentants de l'isère bien
sûr et il y à quelque chose qui est un
petit peu qui peut sembler artificiel
voilà je vous dis vraiment mon ressenti
cela dit attendons d'avoir fini toutes
les toutes les auditions et on fera
notre rapport
vous avez vu qu'on a continué à
travailler avec calme ténacité
détermination et vous avez eu aussi par
rapport à un certain nombre
d'interrogations ou deux procès qui ont
été fait hier justement je voudrais à
votre réaction à ces propos d'alexandre
benalla qui dit que les parlementaires
dessinateurs sont des petites personnes
qui dit que la commission denquête elle
n'est pas fondée par rapport à la
constitution par rapport à la
démocratique quand on voit le
comportement de monsieur benalla en
particulier le 1er mai je ne sais pas
s'il est le mieux placé pour donner des
leçons de moralité aux parlementaires
quand il dit je ne viendrai pas eh bien
il méconnaît tout simplement eu la loi
qui s'applique à tous les français il
n'y a personne qui soit supérieur à
quelqu'un d'autre devant la loi tous les
français sont égaux et moi je n'ai
jamais cru qu'il ne viendrait pas voyez
vous il a 10 à 14 heures avec philippe
bas nous sommes intervenus sur beaucoup
de médias en particulier à public sénat
pour dire mais il ne peut pas ne pas
venir parce que sans cela de toute façon
les choses sont très claires
nous pouvons faire appel le président
peut faire appel à la force publique
et s'il refuse de s'exprimer
eh bien il ya des sanctions pénales qui
sont prévues donc tout citoyen doit
contribuer au travail du sénat et de
l'assemblée nationale d'ailleurs kiki et
vous savez notre travail les double
premièrement faire la loi
deuxièmement contrôler le pouvoir
exécutif donc tout ce qui relève de
l'état des services publics et nous
sommes dans ce travail nous avons une
mission très importante et toutes les
personnes que nous convaincrons doivent
participer alors on nous a dit aussi
mais vous allez en biais des sur la
justice eh bien regardez ce matin nous
avons pris un soin extrême à ne jamais
interrogé quiconque sur une question qui
relève de la justice
nous nous intéressons à l'organisation
de l'état et déboires public c'est
différent